hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be tackling the
very popular and controversial weight
loss program
known as bright line eating i have
avoided this one for a while now because
this one kind of messed with my mind but
it's finally time i broke my silence
now i'm just with you guys i just get a
lot of requests because there is a lot
of wellness to debunk but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
billbar guys
these are good like these are really
really good i don't usually like protein
bars
i mean i don't like chalk masquerading
as food
but i like these bars they taste like
chocolate
but bonus they've got a lot of protein
in them so
today's flavor busting into a fresh box
feels so good you gotta sing it
i don't know if i've tried this brownie
peanut butter what
i mean talk about two amazing worlds
colliding
this would be so good on like yogurt
or sometimes what i do is like i melt it
in the microwave for like 10 seconds
and then i put whipped cream on top yeah
i usually have one before bed
but if i were to do this as like a
post-workout snack
i would probably throw in some fruit or
some oats this would be really good
on oats as well so if you want to try
these out yourself
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code
abbiesharp15 for 15 off of your order
also before we dive deeper into
reviewing this program
i want to provide a quick disclaimer
which you can find on screen
and in the description below including a
trigger warning
since we will be talking about
restrictive eating behaviors
also this video is not meant to shame
anyone who may use brightline eating
or who may have in the past this is
simply
my review of the program and my
professional opinions about its claims
finally don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode
oh okay folks if you are not familiar
with bright line eating aka ble it's a
weight loss program
founded by susan pierce thompson a
self-diagnosed recovering
food addict with a phd in brain and
cognitive science
the program claims to be a
scientifically grounded
program that teaches you a simple
process for getting your brain
on board so that you can finally live
happy
thin and free i mean
sounds tempting and super legit
right well let's see so
the theory behind brightline eating is
that certain foods are
addictive and being a food addict is the
primary cause of obesity
now the company uses a supposed
addiction model
similar to that used by unofficial
organizations like
food addicts anonymous or faa
likening the process of recovery to that
of overcoming like a smoking addiction
note that this is not a legitimate
validated model or treatment protocol
as the mere existence of food addiction
is actually
still up for debate in the medical
community but more on that
very soon like faa the brightline eating
program encourages you to cut out
everything you're allegedly addicted to
completely
and all at once in fact the program
takes an explicit stance against the
concept of moderation now to encourage
one to overcome their alleged food
addiction which again i will get to
soon the program features four bright
lines
which are defined as clear unambiguous
boundaries the idea behind this whole
bright line situation
is that by setting boundaries or let's
be honest and call them what they are
hard restrictive rules you will of
course lose weight
sounds like every other fad diet
ever but yeah moving on
the bright lines are number one
obviously
no sugar shocking i know but not just
the refined white stuff
but also no honey no agave no stevia no
truvia no juice no dried fruit
and no artificial sweeteners only whole
real fruit
is fine in terms of sugar bright line
number two
is no flour and actually even flowers
like almond and
coconut are also off limits susan claims
that the processing
and refining a flour makes it affect the
brain
like a drug now while processed and
refined flour
may not be as nutrient dense comparing
it to a drug
is a complete misrepresentation of any
and
all of the research that we have to date
and as a woman with a doctorate degree
i'm dr sheldon cooper bs ms
m a phd and scd
omg right one would think that she knows
how
to read and interpret research
but alas here we are bright line number
three
is that you're only to have three meals
a day with
no eating in between in one of her vlogs
susan claims that
by letting ourselves snack in between
set meal times
we give ourselves permission to eat all
day long
and therefore will eat too much food ugh
now i know this woman has a phd and
stuff but she does know that you
can overeat at meal times too right
and in fact if we really want to get
technical and fight dirty with poor
science
that there's actually a slight metabolic
advantage to having
smaller meals more often yeah
anyways more on that faulty logic soon
but
finally brightline 4 is that food
quantities must be heavily controlled
and manipulated this means that
everything you're eating
should be meticulously weighed and
portioned out
and you're not allowed to eat more even
if you're left
unsatisfied which come on you
definitely would be on a boring plan
like this what bothers me the most about
this bright line
is not the fact that most members cite
only getting around 1200 calories which
by the way is only enough for my
three-year-old toddler
or doodle poppy not a human adult
but it's the fact that susan claims that
this structure
gives you food freedom what the actual
can we stop co-opting anti-diet rhetoric
to sell
obviously restrictive and borderline
starvation-based diets
there's nothing freeing about being told
you can't have
any flour any sugar any snacks
oh and weigh your food at a restaurant
dinner party because
hey that is the food freedom way if this
is what food freedom looks like in real
life susan
lock me up i'm getting a little bit
spicy already
but obviously there is a lot to unpack
with these four
pivotal bright lines however i also want
to flag one of the most
unintuitive recommendations of the
brightline program
the controversial fifth brightline so to
speak
and that is that members are told not to
exercise
what now some sane people might justify
this by saying
well i guess they don't want a lawsuit
when somebody passes out and hits their
head doing a boot camp class
while consuming half of their caloric
needs but obviously
that's not the rationale that susan
gives
susan claims that exercise has no effect
on weight loss
and that instead what it does is that it
will burn up your
willpower that you need to stick to your
diet
so yeah let's talk about this first of
all
it is true that diet is statistically a
greater contributor to the weight loss
equation
but it doesn't mean that exercise has no
effect one meta-analysis of the research
suggested that both
exercise-only interventions and those
focused on
exercise combined with lifestyle changes
did result
in fat loss and improved body
composition another study also found
that when exercise was combined with
dietary changes
the individuals experienced a greater
percentage of fat loss
when compared to individuals who
participated in diet
only interventions and they were also
able to sustain their weight loss
longer than with diet alone likely
because
exercise can increase muscle mass to
support metabolism
and even if exercise had little effect
on weight loss
which some studies do in fact show
we know that there are dozens of
arguably more important reasons
to move including reducing the risk of
heart disease
osteoporosis high blood pressure stroke
and even mental health issues like
depression and anxiety
anyways moving on to the meal plan
now before we dive into more detail on
those bright lines
i want to take a wee look at what
susan's meal plan would suggest
so the book suggested portions for women
apparently look like this
which puts most people around the 1200
calorie mark
with a number of users suggesting that
they don't even get to meet that
as one user shared this is essentially
what that would look like in real life
sad i know now it's worth pointing out
that this
unfortunate day of eating was actually a
bit of a cheat day for this poor user
since she also had some kind of snack of
like a veggie cake
which put her over her calories by 72.3
so i genuinely hope she wasn't
disciplined too
harshly for her diet transgression but
speaking of harsh cruel
treatment it's important to point out
that if you were to attempt this
punishment of a diet while going out to
like a dinner party
or work lunch you would need to make
sure that you found a handbag
that fit your food scale inside yep
you're required to weigh everything you
eat
including food prepared outside the home
i don't know about you
but i feel pretty triggered just
imagining
having to like weigh out my cherry
tomatoes
in front of my colleagues or friends so
that brings me to
my beef and get settled in folks
because there's a lot let's talk about
the major problems
with bright line eating the food
addiction model they're using is based
on faulty research
so as mentioned before susan compares a
sugar addiction to an addiction to drugs
which i've actually spoken about ad
nauseam in my video
right here but let's do a really quick
recap on what the evidence says
so a lot of the headlines around this
concept center around research that was
done on
rats which showed a dopamine response to
sugar
similar to that of hard drugs there's
also evidence in rats that
when sugar was taken away they exhibited
signs of depression and anxiety as well
as increases in acetylcholine
like we see in substance abuse
withdrawal but evidence against the
sugar addiction model suggests
that while we do see a dopamine response
to sugar
it doesn't have the same neural
hijacking pattern
that something like cocaine does
furthermore
we see the same dopamine response to
other positive
non-addictive behaviors and stimuli like
music
humor seeing a loved one holding a baby
and smiling more importantly the
conclusions
of that landmark rap study i mentioned
actually found
that that drug-like response to sugar
was
only apparent when the wrath had
previously been
restricted of sugar this means that when
rats were able to have sugar whenever
they desired
their brains did not light up the same
way
as they would on opioids in fact they
responded to sugar
like they would respond to any type of
food the authors
say it beautifully intermittent access
is
critical to the development of binging
this paradigm promotes a form of eating
under uncertainty
because food availability is
unpredictable and
guess what creates a perfect storm for
eating under uncertainty
oh i don't know maybe a bogus fad diet
with
too few calories and too many rules oh
snap
yeah that's what i thought now it's
worth pointing out that other research
unrelated to the food addiction model
suggests that binging
often follows a period of restriction
one study looking at the characteristics
of individuals who struggled with
binging
found significantly higher levels of
dietary restraint
or restriction these individuals also
felt
more feelings of deprivation an
exaggerated response to food
and impaired satiety cues which really
shouldn't come
as a surprise if you're a regular abby's
kitchen viewer
you might also recall me often talking
about the satisfaction hunt
and how deprivation is often the
instigator
for an innocent binge you know you want
the ice cream you're not supposed to
have
so you have the fat free plain yogurt
obviously
that doesn't do the trick so you move on
to the protein bar
but no not quite then you eat an entire
pint of that
keto ice cream in the freezer before you
cave and say
it and eat the whole ben and jerry's tub
too
had you perhaps allowed yourself to have
a mindful bowl of ice cream
you could have quelled that binge and
guilt cycle before it started
and ultimately taken in way fewer
calories in the process
i know this is easier said than done for
some folks with long-standing histories
of overeating
and a lot of people do need more
structure so i don't want to undermine
that reality
but i'm just pointing out that overt
extreme restriction
is not helpful for most people either
and in almost all cases
there can be and should be a more
thoughtful middle ground and that brings
me to my next
big issue with brightline there is no
screening
or protection related to disordered
eating
new visitors to the website are
encouraged to take the
food susceptibility quiz which contains
questions related to one's food
struggles within the last three months
for example there's questions like how
much were you able to control the amount
of food you ate
how much do you feel your cravings
control you how often did you binge
etc the problem with this is that a lot
of the behaviors that the quiz
is asking you about are actually common
disordered eating behaviors
so for example binging and preoccupation
or obsessive thoughts about food nowhere
is it suggested to folks who check off
often in these relation to these boxes
that they should abort brightline's
mission and seek professional help
rather the solution is always one of
brightline eating's problematic
restrictive eating programs
and folks that's not cool so to test
this out myself
i purposefully took the quiz myself and
selected all the red flag options such
as
i experienced frequent severe binges and
i received the highest score that you
can get aka
i was identified as being highly
susceptible to
food addiction after this i received a
promo video about how to start the
program
of course and i was given no suggestions
that i may be at risk for disordered
eating
or to seek professional help i also
tried the opposite strategy
and i selected the lowest risk options
such as
i never binged and i was not preoccupied
with thoughts about food
and guess what same spiel
what is the point of a quiz if it tells
me
nothing individualized about my care
obviously
this is not a personalized program but
it's also potentially really dangerous
one
considering the risk associated with
another restrictive diet
for somebody who is clearly struggling
in the relationship with food
which brings me to my third reason why
this program
needs to go and that is the problematic
disordered diet culture messages
so the first thing i want to address
came up in one of susan's videos that i
came across
on her website where she was talking
about weighing
food let's take a look structure
produces freedom freedom from obsession
freedom from
wondering if you've eaten the right
amount or not people who say i don't
want to measure my
food i say try it for a few days and
they write me things like susan
i love measuring my food so much if i if
i experienced
my house burning down around me i would
grab my cat and my digital food scale
and run out the door um
you'd be surprised it's amazing to weigh
and measure your food and experience
how structure produces freedom what the
actual now as usual
i'm not here to diagnose anything but
that is an incredibly
disordered statement to make and it is
really alarming to me
that a phd wouldn't see that as a red
flag
not only is this kind of dedication
rewarded in the system
but as susan says and i quote it's
amazing to weigh
and measure your food and experience how
structure produces
freedom no lady there is nothing freeing
about
weighing out your pee now while we're on
the topic of weighing food
reviewers of the program have stated
that bringing their food scale to
restaurants and social events to weigh
out their food
made them feel embarrassed again this is
not shocking to me
other problematic messages that this
company has been known for
includes statements like hunger is not
an emergency with
program materials explicitly suggesting
that you ignore
your hunger cues no licks bites or
tastes while cooking
with program members suggesting that
susan's helpful tip
is to put tape over your mouth while
you're cooking so that you don't
accidentally lick the spoon what
the actual also we can't forget about
their obsession with finding the
right size body which of course
perpetuates the fat phobic assumption
that there is a one size fits all for
health and let's not forget about their
catchphrase
live happy thin and free i mean
those three words cannot possibly
coexist
on a messed up program like this you
might be thin
but you are certainly not free and i
can't imagine that most people would be
very happy either
you also do not need to be thin to find
happiness
just in case you needed to hear that too
now i'm sure that with all things
this kind of tough love approach works
for some people
and they're able to just like do the
diet and not let it interfere with their
enjoyment of life
but from my research a lot of the
ex-users opened up about how the program
caused
serious disordered eating tendencies
like binge eating
and as we've already established the
research suggests that
this outcome only makes sense now if i
haven't already talked you out of this
program
i just want to end on a more utilitarian
note and that is that brightline is
expensive as so first of all to get
started
you'll want to buy the book which is
about 25 to 30 usd
then to do the 14 day challenge to
help you plan and prep for this way of
eating and living that's going to run
you about 14
cool moving on next comes their
eight-week bootcamp program which costs
you about 500
and believe it or not it actually used
to cost just under a grand
and when you are committed to ble as a
way of life you get onto their
subscription service for
474 dollars per year and if you don't
sign up within three days of completing
the boot camp
that price jumps to almost 950
this doesn't even take into account the
added costs
related to participation like a digital
food scale
plus all of the whole fresh real food
that susan recommends and despite
spending over a thousand
dollars you aren't even seeing anyone
face to face there's no
access to professional support like a
registered dietitian or licensed
therapist
in fact in one of her videos susan says
it's not my area of expertise nor is it
the area of expertise of
anyone at brightline eating i got 27
employees
and none of us are an expert in
nutrition
not even close uh
shouldn't that be a red flag so to
summarize
do not waste your hard earned cash on a
problematic
and dangerous program like brightline
eating
it's based on faulty science preys on
folks who have likely disordered
relationships with food
who could benefit from legitimate
professional help
and not only doesn't actually help them
but it could very well make their health
much worse is losing a quick 10 pounds
really worth all that i think not so on
that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today thank you again to billbar for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it please be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next or
what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you